why are you in your costume costume this is
a uniform and it's brand new so i'm gonna
stretch it out make it more comfortable before
going to mission maybe i'm stupid but why would
you even want to wear that on a mission a bright
red shirt and white pants aren't exactly conducive
to lurking in the shadows people see this uniform
and strikes fear in their hearts what people the
other people at the village people try out why
is there a bald eagle in your car that's equal
you guys are worried without me eagley is
your pet eagle yeah is your dog named doggie
all right do you have a daughter named
daughtery jealous of a guy's pet eagle much
to me peacemaker he's the saddest character
in the whole thing he has the most difficulty
connecting to another human being because
he doesn't feel like he belongs i think
liberty is just your excuse to do whatever
you want we talked a lot about backstory
james is like hey man be like a douchey captain
america who would shoot a kid okay i got it
peacemaker starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection no peacemaker's
a lot of guys i grew up with it's just a rash
that's a rash i mean he is this sort of dude bro
like a lot of dude bros he didn't have a great
father didn't have any mother his father was a
soldier who trained his son how to kill from the
moment he was born blood sport it's like i'm the
leader peacemaker's like you're the leader i
always hit my target's dead center get them
more in the senate it's toxic masculinity at its
most toxic he just wants to be seen and there's
like a lot of psychological subtext there as well
get off of me for him tightly whitey's really no
that's just racist how sad is he that he feels
like he's an outsider in any room that he sits
in that he is desperate to be dominant because he
doesn't feel like he belongs you see it when he's
sitting in the background of the bus as the other
characters are talking and he doesn't say a word
he's very socially awkward something as simple
as the uniform hits on the head that this guy
has validation problems no one has to show off
unless what they're showing off as dope as if
you're doing covert ops you wear something
like idris character you try not to be seen
this is a guy who wears a large chrome helmet
everything is red white blue and yellow
this man genuinely thinks he's a hero and
wants his peacemaker logo on everything
every time i look over at john and he's wearing
that silver toilet on his head it's not a toilet
seat it's a beacon of freedom ah it's the best
you know it's so ridiculous these are the moments
gentlemen drink them in john cena caught me so
unexpectedly i mean people think his superpower is
that he's super strong and he's a good actor but
his ability to make us all laugh is his superpower
cena is the best improv artist i've ever worked
with in my life and i've worked with a lot of
comedian head to the second floor shower stall
three sixteen hundred and thirty hours his name's
felipe but they call him the bloodhound i'm
not going to shower with you pal while we've
been shooting he's been teaching himself how
to play piano that's crazy to me he's an alien
and he's like the hugest person i've ever seen
in my life the thing that was most difficult
was learning to sword fight in high heels
peacemaker's not really as tall as you think he is
to be able to humanize his character fully and
get to the bottom of who he is and what makes
him the way he is is what drove me to do the
tv show with him what do you guys want him for
just to save the world that's all and that
kind of let loose this odd character we have
you know i think there's a lot of shades of
grey with these characters and the same thing
with peacemaker and his lofty ideals keeping
the peace is worth any price i'm excited about
having them appear in movies and in tv i'm having
an amazing time doing peacemaker on hbo max
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going to
be my new peacemaker hbo trailer they just
dropped a bunch of new footage so we'll break it
down obviously a bunch of funny easter eggs here
referencing justice league suicide squad movie
stuff so if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes i will be doing
episode videos for when it releases in january
we'll be getting even more footage of dc
fandom this weekend too when it's going to
be like trailer city like the batman trailer
trailers for all the upcoming movies like the
flash movie trailer i'll be doing videos for all
that stuff as well too but the whole thing in the
peacemaker trailer here is them just clowning
on him for being such a douche walking around
in public with this really bright costume
that just screams i'm looking for attention
when they're actually supposed to be running
all these black ops missions for amanda waller
like wouldn't you rather be a little more stealth
if we're going to be doing all this crazy stuff
and the rest of their team just absolutely
convinced all unanimous that they're being
completely screwed by amanda waller and this
is just retaliation them having to deal with
him because of what they did revolting against
her during the events of the suicide squad movie
and i love the way they call out his pet bald
eagle in his backseat and the fact that he calls
it eagerly no joke his pet bald eagle is just
named eagerly and i love the way the rest of the
group just absolutely could not stand him like
they're calling him out on all this weird stuff
that he does just being a complete douche and
he just casually brushes it off like the only
thing he has to say to all this is wait a
minute did you guys just order without me
and his whole reason for wearing the uniform
to their little dinner meeting here is because
he wants to stretch it out so that it's more
comfortable during their upcoming mission if
the timeline wasn't clear between this and the
suicide squad movie there's a bit of a time jump
because he's recovered it's meant to be a sequel
series to the suicide squad movie so enough time
has gone by that he's recovered in the hospital
and he's back to 100 percent but the mission that
he's talking about when they're sitting down for
dinner here is the first big mission that they're
going on is part of the peacemaker series the
basic idea being that it's the same suicide squad
dynamic from the movie it's just a portion
of the people under amanda waller from argus
are now going to be dealing with this so a lot of
people from the movie will be coming back in this
with a couple of brand new characters that you've
already seen in some of the other trailer footage
like you've already seen the dceu version of
vigilante they did a version of him on arrow
a long time ago but this one's a little bit more
comic book accurate and as you can see from their
comedic shootout moment here they're playing
him in the tone of the peacemaker character
like john cena's peacemaker sort of informs the
whole tone of the series like it's going to be
crazy in a really ridiculous kind of way a giant
shiny wrecking ball just mowing through everything
in his path completely unself-aware about all the
really wtf weird stuff that he does james gunn and
john cena both kind of clarify why peacemaker is
so weird during that feature red after this too
the whole idea being that he's desperate he's
thirsty for validation he'll do anything to
get it so that's how amanda waller manipulates
him like using validation as his kryptonite to
make a superman reference because we're in the dc
universe amanda waller makes him feel like he's
important and needed so he just does whatever she
tells him to do no matter how shady or how much it
puts him at odds with his other teammates that's
why he was so conflicted during the suicide squad
movie when he kills rick flag and tries to kill
ragcatcher because he's psyched himself into this
place mentally where he believes everything amanda
waller has told him keeping the peace is his whole
thing no matter how many people he has to kill
men women or children i feel like all the scenes
from the suicide squad movie of him in the tidy
whities and then the footage of him in the tidy
whities from the peacemaker trailer dancing around
to his records in his trailer tells you everything
you need to know about his character they have an
absolutely confirmed which other big dc crossover
characters are going to appear in the series but
they did say that the peacemaker episodes would
set up future dc projects they didn't say suicide
squad sequels or anything like that they just said
other upcoming dc movies and dc hbo series
there'll be eight episodes total they haven't
confirmed an absolute release date yet but i think
it's supposed to be the second or the third week
in january so it'll be kind of like one division
premiering in january this past year and i will do
episode videos for all the dc hbo series just like
i've been doing for the marvel disney plus series
it'll be the exact same situation i'm hoping at
dc fandom they confirm when that first batman hbo
series the big spin-off from the robert pattinson
movie is going to premiere next year because i
don't think that matt reeves has even started
filming that yet and it basically is a matt
reeves production the same way that james gunn did
the suicide squad movie then is doing the suicide
squad sequel series the real big stuff that's
happening this weekend will be the brand new
batman trailer also the flash movie trailer with
michael keaton's batman ben affleck's batman we'll
probably see some footage of them in the movie
and learn a little bit more about what's going
on with the villain because of the flashpoint of
it all i've already done a couple videos about
that so i'll link them below in the description
like i've already done a big first look video for
what ben affleck's character is going to look
like as his batman in the movie it will be set
after the events of the justice league snyder cut
even though if you get really technical about it
some of that stuff is not supposed to be canon
to the dc eu i think the whole nightmare scene
they're considering to not be canon but everything
else through the epilogue is canon to the dc eu
james gunn also revealed that he's working
on another new dc project but he didn't say
whether it's a movie or another hbo series but
he did say that it was not peacemaker season two
it's some other dc project so i'm assuming that
it's a brand new movie so post all your theories
about what movie you think that's going to be
because they pretty much let him do whatever
movie they wanted to in fact i've already done a
video about this but he said that when he first
walked in superman was one of the movies that they
discussed him doing either way john cena is going
to be crazy in this peacemaker series i can't wait
to see it make sure you have alerts enabled so you
don't miss any of my trailer videos this weekend
and there's a couple of the really big videos that
i'm working on right now i'll try to get them out
as fast as possible everyone click here for that
brand new marvel guardians of the galaxy 3 adam
warlock announcement in easter eggs and click
here for that flash movie first look video with
ben affleck's batman and all that new footage
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!